now we gender set joan in syria this
morning he was in Damascus the capital
where the Allied airstrikes began he has
more in the attack Seth good morning
good morning these strikes should not
have come as a surprise but as we have
been reporting from Damascus for the
last couple of days we've heard from a
number of people who told us they
believe that these strikes simply might
happen many others who said that they
believed there wasn't a basis for these
strikes still it was a sleepless night
last night in the capital city the
coalition airstrikes lit up the sky over
Damascus as we were reporting live it
has been quite a morning here though
watching both anti-aircraft fire and
flares going through the sky also
hearing those incoming air strikes among
the targets was this research facility
in Damascus left in ruins early this
morning residents just next door told us
they were jolted awake around 4:00 a.m.
they opened the windows so they wouldn't
break this woman told us protestors
quickly took to the streets this morning
in defiance we are not scared of the
American missiles this protester said we
were in the square not in the shelters
and Syria's propaganda machine was up
and running early to releasing video of
a seemingly relaxed Syrian President
Bashar al-assad gambling into a building
the post on social media said it was a
morning of resilience at a bakery this
morning this woman described how her
house shook and what she heard I
couldn't tell what was going on she said
I saw the flames and the fire
despite the destruction we are already
getting spin from all sides including
reports from Syrian rebels who have said
that these strikes are a farce as long
as President Bashar al Assad stays in
power
Anthony Seth Doane live this morning in
Damascus Syria Thank You Seth